um position number three it's going to
come down into be a pinch
frame position number four you're just
going to drop down it can be on either
leg as long as the string is coming out
to the side that the AR position number
five is going to be the opposite of that
a little awkward but still a great spot
position six is another pinch
frame dominant side position seven
non-dominant side position eight
between the legs all of these frames can
be
expanded if they
drop they can be you know
bent ples they can be
inverted um but most of the tricks I'm
going to show you our regular can you
show those all really fast again though
yeah position one position two position
three position four position five
position six position s position eight
um so driving po there's a few ways we
can go about this first is going to be
head L coming in and
out then start to move through there
that gives you another opportunity to
come out for a more consistent
move also as we just covered
um out this
way continuous
push we can do handle stuff so pendulum
under the arm hope with the handle and
it's great to follow
those
um over we can toss through so basic
toss
through basic tosses more advanced
tosses um we then started going through
some more kind of unique
stuff outs
any way to link these together which is
where we start getting into what we call
positive space one now we have two
negative spaces two negatives make a
positive
right there's all kinds of circuits we
can build
there um we went through folding there's
a great way one to learn an
inversion which is a form of negative
space um it also leads to
those can be bent and apply into new
spots as
[Music]
well uh another form of double negative
space we covered is using your body as a
frame as well as the point you have
multiple places that you can kind of
play with
uh we went over some double
pinches
spot um went over some contact rols
really
briefly uh yep we went through these
elbow push throughs
which can be applied to move from one
spot to the other they also can be done
in Reverse to
backtrack more
difficultly um what else should we
cover I don't know what else we
talking there's a sequence that went
from the top down to the leg and there's
one that stayed in the inversion that
you like went from the shoulder to the
pinch back and
forth oh I know what else went over
that's on
video cover in some different ways to
get the web
catches um easiest way position
one get out of it just kind of grab a
head over something will Shing which is
cool oh oh oh hat
man
yes
dude simultaneous hat manipulation
that's minutes not working Sun got me
yeah that's a lot of negative space
stuff
Platinum while thanks Adam chemist pack
fire 1998